Now let's take a look at what we did here.
So we had re.split and then this regular expression and then out of the formula.
So what does this say?
This says I want to split up the original formula, and the way I'm splitting it up is
I'm taking sequences of the characters A-Z in a row.
The plus means one or more, and the parentheses means keep that result.
So when I have you = me squared,
this part and this part will match,
and they'll be returned as individual elements in this split,
and so will the other parts.
Re.split will return the list consisting of the parts that it found in the split
plus everything in between.
And it will be this type of list, and then I'm going to map compile word--
it didn't quite fit on one line--
to re.split, and that will give me--
these tokens will remain unchanged,
and these will be converted into the form that multiplies out the digits.
Then I'm going to assign that to the variable tokens.
Now I've got my tokens.
The body of the function we just formed by concatenating all the tokens together.
If I wanted to I could put spaces between them; it doesn't matter.
And the function is lambda created with the parameters in the body,
and then I just return the evaluation of the function,
so that complies the function, does it only once rather than once per permutation.
And I return the letters that I found.
As a convenience, because when you're debugging this function you may want
to say, "Well, what did this function look like?"
"What did I come up with? What did I come up with?"
I have an optional parameter here
I have an optional parameter here that says if you pass in verbose equals true,
then it just prints out what it found.
It just makes it a little bit easier to debug this function.
And now, when I run profiling again, look what I get.
The time has sped up quite a bit on the simple list of 14 examples that we saw before.
This version of the code is 25 times faster.
On a more complex list, it's only 13 times faster.
But it's at least an order of magnitude faster.
And we did that because we eliminated calls to eval.
So we found the bottleneck.
We found that eval was the function that was taking up the most amount of time
in the previous profiling.
We figured out a way to call eval less often by precompiling,
and now we've done away with that difficulty.